my name is Paul fine I'm the director of
the film I want to thank you all for
coming out tonight and I wanted to thank
you more importantly for your interest
in drug policy last night I had a dream
I had a dream it was at a cocktail party
with Barack Obama and I got him into the
corner of the room and I said mr.
president you know what are you gonna do
about drug reform in your second term
and he said you know what I care a lot
about drug policy reform I've always
been passionate about it but there are
bigger fish to fry we've got problems in
Syria we've got a health care debate we
have budget problems at home and then he
started to tell Ori and I was thinking
to myself you know I wanted to tell him
you could really add to your legacy if
you were to make some changes right now
and at that point the alarm went off in
my hotel room the alarm that had been
set by the previous occupant of the room
and so I didn't get to continue the
conversation with President Obama but
I'm very pleased that we're able to
continue this conversation here tonight
and going into the future and so right
now I'd like to introduce we have John
Tierney of the New York Times excuse me
Melissa mark-viverito she's a New York
City Council member Ethan Adelman
ethan Adelman of the drug policy
alliance and finally Mary O'Grady of the
Wall Street Journal I'm gonna ask each
of the panelists to talk just for a few
minutes to give their perspective on
current on the current drug drug
prohibition debate and then we'll open
it up for some questions and answers
Mary would you like to start sure okay
well my instructions from the moderator
that I have five minutes to tell you all
of my views on the war on drugs which is
quite brief so I just decided to break
it down into three things I write for
The Wall Street Journal I write a column
a weekly column called the Americas
which is about the Americas outside of
the United States so most of the focus
is on Latin America a little bit of
Canada and so the first thing that I
want to the first point I want to make
is just that in 20 years of doing this
job the cost of the current drug policy
has been really my issue I know that
there's a lot of conversation about how
the drug policy affects Americans living
in this country but the cost to
developing countries of our war on drugs
has been extremely high and debilitating
not just for individuals who get caught
in the crossfire but also for the
broader ability of these countries to
develop residents Latin American
presidents have talked to me about the
way that the organized crime networks
which get so much money from the cartels
are able to overwhelm these very frail
states and as we know from the work of
The Economist Douglas north who won the
Nobel Prize institutions are very
important for development and if you
don't have strong independent
institutions it's very hard to get over
a lot of the problems associated with
being a poor country and really
institutional development
been greatly hampered by the fact that
these organized criminal networks used
the money they have to to corrupt the
institutions and weaken the ability of
those institutions to basically defend
the rule of law um the second point I
want to make is just about the failure
and obviously you just saw this film so
you know all about the failure but I was
struck just overnight I think it was
yesterday the news that came from France
about the drug bust of 1.3 tonnes of
cocaine that were found in a plane going
from Venezuela to France and it reminded
me that some of you may know that former
Secretary of State George Shultz is also
against the current policy of our
current drug policy and he likes to tell
the story of being with former senator
daniel patrick moynihan way back when I
think it was in the 70s and he was in a
car going out to Camp David with with
the senator and the senator said to him
hey great news we busted the French
Connection and George Shultz said you
know he just kept doing his work in the
limo and he didn't really answer and
Moynihan was like no no don't you see we
busted the French Connection and he
didn't answer and finally Moynihan said
to him I bet you're one of those people
who think that as long as we have strong
demand for drugs in this country we're
not going to be able to win the war on
drugs and George Shultz claims that he
looked at him and said Moynihan there's
hope for you yet and when I heard about
this drug bust yesterday I thought you
know did daniel patrick moynihan ever
imagine that so many years later we
would still be you know chasing drugs
around the jungles the the unday in
jungles and making these sighs drug
busts am i running out of time I have
one more point to make and that is then
I asked myself looking at the high cost
and the obvious failure to achieve
anything why doesn't it
and on that I just want to make two
points one obviously there's a lot of
interests I mean there are a lot of
people who make money off of chasing
drug people around the jungle and trying
to defoliate the the South American
continent but the second thing is I
think that there's a lot of fear on the
part of people who are against this and
this is where I think you know those of
us who are in favor of changing the
policy have to try to empathize with
those the legitimate fear that people
have that one there'll be a spike in use
and two that the cost will be shifted on
to you know them in other words people
that people will start using drugs more
and then there'll be a higher health
care cost and that cost will land on
people who are not involved with it at
all and so that moral hazard I think is
also a big concern on the part of people
who oppose a change in policy and lastly
let me just say that I think when we're
trying to market this idea we should
admit that it's not a panacea that there
will be problems from it what we have to
try to communicate is that there are
costs and benefits to any policy and
right now the costs way outweigh the
benefits and we should try to find
something where the costs are lower and
that they and where those costs land on
those people who are engaged in that
activity not on innocent people and
where the benefits are higher that's
I'll finish there thank you
and Melissa would you like to go next
well good evening everybody and I think
I feel kind of a little bit of the place
on this panel but I think that I really
want to him in the film
you know I think it really obviously
puts a lot of information out there and
as you're watching it it was very
heartbreaking but also very overwhelming
right sometimes it feels like it's an
insurmountable issue to tackle but then
looking you know in terms of really at
the end of the film and looking at it
from the perspective of what can we do
you know at a very local level I think
is the way to begin right and I'm a New
York City legislator so my focus is very
much in terms of local law and
legislation and things pop policies that
we can enact to be more effective and to
be more just and when we look at the
conversation that has ensued in this
mayoral debate around stop and frisk a
subset of the issue that we're dealing
with marijuana arrests we're here in New
York City we have over 50,000 marijuana
arrests happening a year and in a
district like the one that I represent
which is overwhelmingly of color it is
low income within the district that I
represent of East Harlem in the South
Bronx
I have two police precincts that have
the highest stop and frisks in the
respective boroughs so you know the
issue are is very real to my
constituents it's an issue that we deal
with every day and the inefficiency of a
policy that is criminalizing our young
people that is wasting our resources in
ways as the as the film talks about that
could be better spent on strategies that
we know work taking examples of other
countries and other municipalities
things that have worked and strategies
that have worked and we really have a
hard time I think in this country on
accepting that we have things to learn
from other places and so from a very
local perspective you know knowing when
we discuss the city budget every year
that about seventy five million dollars
is being wasted in the amount of time
that police officers are going after
such a low-level offense and the
implications that that has not only
financially but socially within our
communities right well you know you have
a young person primarily because these
are young people of color
african-american and Latino
that now how going through a system
sometimes are 24 hours for again a
marijuana arrest you're having police
officers taken off the street to deal
with this low-level offense and then
you're having young people sometimes who
are put in jail and then they have
difficulties when they come out right so
there's a lot of implications for these
policies and as legislators we've got a
look at how we are how we are being
mindful of taxpayer dollars of how we're
effectively investing those monies in a
way that is going to produce tangible
results and so you know I've been really
a strong ally with the drug policy
Alliance and looking at really closing
the loopholes in the state law you know
New York State did decriminalize the
possession of up to 25 grams of
marijuana and the only way that you can
get arrested is if it's in public view
or being smoked and what officers here
in New York City have been doing is that
in the process of a stop and frisk for
instance if they do stop a young person
and the person has a joint in their
pocket and they happen to take it out in
the process of that arrest now that it's
in public view they're arresting that
young person right and that's not the
way the law was written that's not the
intent of the law so the idea of closing
the loophole is something that we're
fighting at the state level where we
have a Republican Senate that refuses
I'm sorry a Republican Republicans in
the Senate that are refusing to support
the this you know closing of the
loophole so there's work that we need to
do with our allies and and with all of
you in terms of really making the
message and taking the message to
legislators but I really want to commend
the work that many of you are doing and
for this film I think it really brings
it home and and for myself that
represents a constituency that deals
with this issue each and every day I
just see how unjust it is how
ineffective it is and that we have a
long way to go but that we need to
continue to fight the good fight
I'm John Tierney and I want a really
Paul and David and for the film it's
just it is really heartwarming to see it
I've been writing about this for a long
time and I I know some of the people in
the movie and Ethan and Radley Balko and
you know they've just been doing amazing
work and it's so frustrating when you
cover this for a while and see how great
the arguments are how terrible the
stories are and things don't change now
watching the story about Robert Moss
reminded me last year for the New York
Times I did a series about incarceration
and I did one article about people
serving mandatory life sentences with no
parole for drugs and there were just
awful stories that people were
nonviolent they you know some of them
had been you know there was a Grateful
Dead head who was caught with some LSD
that they trumped up the weight they
counted the paper that the blotter was
on and sent him to prison for life
there's a woman who's whose boyfriend
it's towards some some drugs in her
house without her knowledge and you know
he got out in a few years as did
everyone else but she's serving life
without parole and there were about five
stories like this I wrote about and and
they were all terrible stories and these
are cases where the judges were saying
in fact in all the cases the judges have
said this is a terrible injustice I
don't want to do this please I hope
someone on does this and in some of the
cases the prosecutors were saying look I
have to do this but please I hope when
their appeal comes up with someone
should do something about this and after
I I did the series I heard from the
lawyers I've been talking to them and
and there was a lot of hope that around
Christmas time for the new year they
were hearing rumors that the White House
had been asking for the files of these
people and that after all this publicity
in The Times something would happen and
you know and so New Year's comes and
nothing happens at all and that is
really I mean Obama I mean to me it's
it's it's it's really appalling to see
this is a bipartisan failure I mean I
endure I've debated this with people on
both sides of the aisle with Bill
Kristol why is a weekly standard you
know railing against drugs I've debated
it with prosecutors and
in in case I've done with Bush's drug
czar and it amazes me that you know that
people intelligent people can look at
this failed war and see the cost and all
these things and still keep supporting
it and I'm not completely hopeless and
this kind of movie makes me feel you
know more hopeful about it as to why
this goes on you know from from covering
it for a while I just think it is an
amazing example of how corrupting
government is and how corrupting federal
power is because this Paul makes so
clear in the movie these things wouldn't
be done these swat teams wouldn't be
breaking down houses if people actually
had to pay for this in their own
neighborhood but at the federal level it
just becomes this issue of money that's
being able to be dispensed its power
that's being given and no one's really
accountable for it and it's something
you know that you see on both sides
Republicans love to moralize about it
Democrats you know they're not so moral
about this and Obama of course is not is
himself a user but they stay I've
wondered why don't liberals take this
more seriously and I sometimes think
it's really because they may like drugs
or they may hate drug laws but they love
big government even more and you see
these very unholy alliances and
Republicans and Democrats with prison
guard unions with police forces that are
all profiting from this war and it's
simply nobody really wants to stand up
and take the money away
what I find hopeful though is seeing a
movie like this seeing what reason does
for this and seeing you know the army of
David as Glenn Reynolds calls it that
you know that the the sentiment of the
public sentiment against drugs is very
strong but it's never really had a voice
because the establishment at both the
local and the federal level you know
there's a lot of money in it for people
there but you know people who see this
effect on their families and their
communities are not in favor of it it
was striking I think when the White
House
had a website where they were asking
people what question they asked the
president that the marijuana question
would just come to the top all the time
of course nobody in washington the
washington press corps is really too
sophisticated to care about that anymore
it's you know they know that's this kind
of a
it's sort of one of these strange
libertarian issues but people really do
care about it and I think with the rise
of the Tea Party with Rand Paul see you
know coming out against now against
mandatory minimums I think there's a
chance that there can be you know that
the grassroots can be heard on this and
I hope Rand Paul will make this an issue
I'm not sure you know he's how strong he
is on drugs I know he's trying to he's
trying to play the conservative base but
I think that you know the more we have
the web thanks to the web we have more
of a chance for people to actually rally
around this issue and to make some
headway against these established forces
that are doing it and finally they you
know there is some hope I think at the
state level that they simply can't
afford to in to incarcerate all these
people anymore and so you are seeing on
both sides of the aisle on you and some
Republican governors have led the way in
this realizing we just can't afford to
keep building prisons to lock these
people up so I'm hoping that between
popular organization this army of David
the that has a way to reach each other
in between fiscal realities that
something can happen but but in the
meantime I think this movie is just an
amazing achievement it's just it's
maddening that's heartwarming at the
same time and congratulations
yeah just second that really excellent
film a congratulations to you and David
not a reason foundation for putting the
resources behind us and putting this out
there
I think what might be most helpful cuz
you already heard me up there you know
the crying how terrible this drug war is
how long it's been going on America's
massive incarceration policy the
incredibly destructive role around the
world not just in Mexico and the
Caribbean Latin America but now in West
Africa and a whole range of other parts
world so enough with that I mean enough
cuz you heard it but I thought what
might be most helpful is just you know
things are moving in a more positive
direction on drug policy reform and
criminal justice reform right now than
at any time in all the years I've been
involved in this and you know it's still
this massive you know ocean liner of a
drug war prison industrial complex
moving forward and with all this
momentum behind it but things are
changing and I just want to pick out a
few things you heard me say Obama was
such a terrible disappointment the
second half of his first term but I'll
say this those guys kept telling us this
is the second term issue if we get a
chance in the last five six weeks
they've been to some extent making good
on that you got Holder standing up five
six weeks ago and announcing the Bar
Association that this issue of over
incarceration is a moral issue and a
fiscal issue in America and a public
safety issue then following up last week
Gresham black caucus and actually
pushing the envelope I'm trying to
reduce federal incarceration as much as
possible given the constraints of
federal law judicial prerogative and the
relative independence of US attorneys
they seem to care about this Holder was
telling people in his first term he
wanted this to be a legacy issue for him
reduce incarceration and we kept going
where is the legacy thanks for the crack
powder reform but where's the rest of it
it looks like something is now beginning
to happen on that front the fact that he
was able to justify this policy by
pointing not just to Democratic but
Republican governors around the country
from Christie and New Jersey to for
mitch Daniels in Indiana to nathan Deal
and George and a whole range of others
who are also beginning to reducing car
duration for fiscal reasons for moral
reasons for other reasons also shows
that we're beginning to see a turn here
now as I said before it's a bit like
turning around an ocean liner you can
start to point in a new direction but it
takes a long time before it really
begins to turn but remember last year
was I think the first one two years ago
was the first year we actually saw a
reduction in overall incarceration in
America last year we saw half the states
reduce their incarceration at least a
little bit so there's a lot of bad stuff
still going on but it's happening and
then of course there's the marijuana
issue look at that Gallup poll that they
put up there where you see 50 percent of
country now saying make it legal I can
tell you there's private and public
polling ranging from Maine and New
Jersey to New Mexico to Y to Oregon even
Louisiana now showing majorities of the
population in favor legalizing marijuana
you're seeing close to over 55 close to
60% in some places it seems to me that
public support in America has jumped 5
or 10 points just in the last year
because the victories in Washington and
Colorado made it feel real well you know
I was wondering what the Obama
administration was gonna do I thought
they'd come out with something sort of a
yellow light like they did with medical
marijuana a few years ago but downlight
was a lot more greenish than I expected
a few weeks ago they basically said to
Washington Colorado we're gonna give you
a chance to implement these new laws
here's our eight criteria you try to
meet those criteria and I think they
were saying that in good faith four
years ago was Obama said during the
campaign he's not gonna have to medical
marijuana what's the least we can give
in order to accommodate that now I think
it was a lot more real on this front so
we're seeing a shift there and I'll tell
you keep your eye on Oregon next year
maybe Alaska next year for legalizing
marijuana more broadly then look at
California and Maine and look at Nevada
look at a whole range of other places
maybe Massachusetts maybe some states in
the south because the numbers are
jumping there quickly so we're seeing a
real shift when I would travel outside
the United States I would typically find
myself apologizing as an American for
the horrific consequences of our us-led
global war on drugs but now I
at least one respect in which I can hold
my head high because who's leading the
world now when it comes to marijuana law
reform it's the United States of America
not at the federal level but at the
levels of public opinion civil society
and state government 20 states that have
legalized medical marijuana a couple
million people illegal marijuana IDs
over a thousand maybe two thousand
dispensaries around the country
Washington and Colorado have legalized
and now the Justice Department given a
little room to run we are leading the
world in that regard and but it's not
just us yesterday the good fortune of a
meeting with president Mujica ahead of
or ago I was in New York the United for
you know for the UN meetings and it
looks like org y could become the first
country to legalize marijuana in the
next month or so right then you look at
Europe the Dutch seemed like they were
pulling back on their cannabis policy
now in fact they're saying let's try to
figure out a way to legalize the whole
thing and you see the Czechs and you see
the Spanish and you see you see you know
a range of other European the Swiss
trying to find other ways to legally
regulate this stuff almost saying
weren't we Europeans at the lead of
sensible drug policy now America's
leading there and Latin American there
and that list of former presidents
Cardozo kuvira's is a deal from Brazil
Colombian Mexico now it's not just
former presidents now you got current
president Mujica I'm in in in or iguana
got Otto Perez Molina from Guatemala
you got Santos from Colombia all calling
into question the basic prohibition is
paradigm we're seeing the challenge
beginning to bubble up there are people
presidents giving speeches at the UN
this week saying we need to move in a
new direction so I don't want to say the
whole house of cards is coming tumbling
down but I can tell you from high levels
to the national security agencies who
want to now talk look to people like me
for the first time in decades to people
involved with the anti-drug campaigns
who are saying wait a second the world's
changing we need to hear from you how do
we deal with these issues something's
really happening I've always been very
cautious about saying we're at a tipping
point you know because you only say that
so many times right
but this is the year I'm saying that
when it comes to marijuana policy I
think we've hit a tipping point the last
point I'm going to say this has been
crucial to who drug policy Alliance is
and and this growing movement we fight
for two things one is to reduce the
harms the government does with its drug
war the incarceration and violence and
wasted money and destruction of lies and
spread the disease and all that and the
other thing we do is to try to reduce
the harms that people do to themselves
with drugs that meant legalizing needle
exchange program in the early years now
it means 911 Good Samaritan laws and
getting the antidote and the locks on
out there so that we don't have so many
people dying from overdoses that's gotta
be the focus the best drug policy we can
have is one that reduces the harms of
drugs and that reduces the harms of the
government's drug control policies we
are turning a corner whether it's the
ocean liner on massive incarceration or
the tipping point on marijuana but I
don't want to leave us all here
depressed
we actually are beginning to make some
real progress well please join me in
thanking all the panelists tonight
you